it's been nearly 60 years since Dr
Martin Luther King Jr gave his famous I
Have a Dream speech and now a new
children's book aims to connect his
words to a new generation the book is
called echo in the distance the author
is Shayla Michelle Reeves and this is
she reading from the book
suddenly Thunder splits the skies
ripping Hearts persecuting lives
splitting the evil dismembering the lies
devouring ignorance and passionate cries
engulfing Injustice entangled in time
swallowing fear and fragile Minds
digesting change desegregating the times
people are people not color-coded crimes
I love that line in the book Shayla
Michelle Reeves wrote those words 20
years ago in a college writing
competition that she won by the way
thank you very much now she's an Emmy
award-winning anchor and reported our
CBS station that's WCCO in Minneapolis
St Paul Shayla good morning to you good
morning to you thank you for having me
well I'm glad you're here WCCO rejected
me back in the day I still have that
rejection letter dear Gail we wish you
luck in your career but unfortunately
blah blah blah okay
I am glad you're here but let's talk
about when you wrote that
um you wrote that 20 years you were a
freshman in college yes what were you
thinking at the time surely you weren't
thinking one day this is going to be a
book what were you saying at the time I
was actually a freshman entering a
writing competition at Northwestern
University they had a written expression
competition for MLK and the winner of
that contest would have a chance to
perform in 2003. so I ended up winning
that competition right performed my
piece into 2003 and at the time I just
was writing what I hoped would be an
exceptional spoken word peace and it was
an honor to perform that piece for the
University I received invitations to
also perform it at DePaul University as
well as a safer foundation in Harvey
Illinois but like anything that you
don't do more with it collects dust over
time right but I always had in the back
of my mind this would be such a great
illustrated book but I just never did
more with it and I didn't have the
resources as a college freshman to do
more with it and then you did more with
it how did you find an illustrator well
Instagram
yes yes
after hearing me talk about it for a
long time my husband said you know what
for your Christmas gift a couple years
ago he said I'm gonna make this your
gifts like paying for you to bring this
into the world because you've been
talking about it for so long
so I had to do all the research into the
illustrator and finding the publisher
and all of that good old Instagram good
old Instagram
um I was on Instagram and uh someone who
had interviewed her name is Audra
Robinson with an awesome product Rocky
Robinson self-care for girls standing
right next to capricia ambers the
illustrator for my book and I said I
wonder who this person is clicked right
on this picture and all these beautiful
illustrations now the two of you have
got a wonderful conference but I like
let's talk about the imagery in your
book because you like you make Martin
Luther King like a superhero yes what is
the message you were sending there yes
so the image I think that connects with
people the most it goes with the line
people are people not color-coded crime
which means what yes so that line what I
really wanted people to take away is
just because of the color of someone's
skin it doesn't mean that they have
Criminal Intent or nefarious motives
it's it because of the color of their
skin it doesn't mean that there's
something bad or terrible on the inside
it's appealing to people to see the
humanity of other people and so the
superhero character
um I'm not even someone who was
connected to superheroes and really
attached to that growing up but I woke
up in the middle of the night and I said
that's what needs to go at that line and
when you think of superheroes or
Superman he's Fair he's confident he's
compassionate he's considerate but
there's something about that particular
character that connects all kinds of
people no matter what people look like
they connect with that particular
character and there's something about
him no matter the race of people they
connect with him and race is the issue
that keeps people divided it's true and
so I said what if you take this
character that is able to transcend this
issue that gets people stuck give them a
little bit more color and then instead
of the S you put a heart on his chest
yeah and voila echo in the distance and
there you have it and and you've been
connecting with kids at school uh what's
it been like speaking in front of that
audience it's been really amazing kids
have some incredible questions and I
think they're honest they are very
honest and I think one of the things
that's been really interesting about
that is they're not only interested in
the book but they're showing me that
they're interested in how I occupy space
and they're showing me that it's not
only interesting for them to see me as a
journalist as a writer but how they too
can occupy space in the world that it's
important for them to see somebody that
can be on television somebody that can
write a book somebody that can
illustrate a book all the things that
they can be in the world standing in
front of them and then telling them that
they can do that too that's right I
think that's valuable and important and
so I think that's important to be in
classrooms and showing them who and how
they can exist in the world as well well
we'll just say this to you Shayla
Michelle Reeves now author
congratulations something tells me this
is not going to be your last book oh
it's not I've already got
yeah the name of your first book is
called echo in the distance it's on sale
now wherever you like to buy your books
thank you